sono tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono famigerata ci siamo su
afterlife gay
ricordate ragazzi life the game quello
questo gioco bello che si vanno a
toccare la corrente elettrica con le
mani si può essere così deficienti io
devo tenerli lontani dalla presa
elettrica del detersivo e dal fuoco
gioco dell'anno dopo light the game
hanno fatto afterlife game quindi cosa
succede dopo la morte play ha ripartito
flyball a hold oddio oddio deve volare
dopo volare in cielo fantastico ha messo
schiantato contro un albero in realtà
prova durante i primi secondi di libertà
come fantasma si è incastrato in un
ostacolo a caso e grazie io era
destinato a spendere l'eternità
contemplando tutte le tue povere
decisioni che ti hanno portato qui mi
son castrato in un albero fantastico che
sarà una cosa che succede quando muori
devi scansare i lampioni ragazzi
veramente ragazzi istruzione da parte di
fa vj questa roba previsto paradiso c'è
luce c'è gesù non paga i gas per
ripetere questa roba a devo ripulire il
mio computer special porno devo pulire
la mia cronologia fantastico è la
madonna inter inter shulman contemplata
banana bene e bellissimo più di flier ce
l'ha scritto dopo la tua morte il tuo
computer è stato ceduto al tuo più
giovane nipote timmy quando l'ha aperto
ha visto tutta quella roba di computer
che lo spaventerà per il resto della
vita ora lui risiede in un ospedale
psichiatrico è la madonna
devo cancellare la mia cronologia
qualche mio nipote non deve vederlo my
little pony via porno via più porno via
specie al porno via dove a questa guerra
un'immagine di me e di mia moglie è
bella ma [ __ ] anno da tenerla
avete qualche la teniamo la via specie
al punto di porno via compreso my little
pony ma non si possono aprire la meglio
in un modo giusto per aprire una
nocciolina ma perché come cucinare un
muffin più di player mark player ti ama
a caso per quale motivo
fatto fatto computer pulito ma come
allora lo sfondo che deficente pisa temi
raga mi sono dimenticato di cambiarlo
così come si cambia lo sfondo a 7 c ok a
forza promessa fi
proteggi che protegga ma questo so io o
di un porcospino a devo proteggere mia
moglie dalle cose dalla dalla merda dai
coltelli dalle mappe non l'ho fatto
apposta
hai fallito nel proteggere tua moglie
del pericolo ora non sei più solo ed è
meglio non try again o continuo
proviamoci di nuovo dai devo proteggere
mia moglie vecchia che se ne sa
bottarella la darei ancora va avanti
perché i ninja spiegava il senso di sto
livello per cortesia barriera che carino
river vendetta a lana lang bastardo di
mio cugino diventato presidente a devo
mandare tutto a [ __ ] fra direbbe che
sono fantasma giusto se starò contratti
o di contratti a minchia vai a lande
morire gioca oddio passo fi gameplay vai
sto giocando visto spaventando
ma cosa c'entra sta cosa ci spiega mente
cosa c'entrava lavico la vita dopo la
morte
che cosa fa un messi a questo è il bar
di morbio che perfetto qual è lo sport
preferito di un messicano attraversare
il paese
vi prego ditemi che l'ha capito che
cos'è bianco e non può scalare gli
alberi e il cigno un frigorifero più di
bahia certo il teoria dovrebbe essere il
fantasma promettiamo più di prima ti
aspettavi una battuta sui fantasmi vero
è effettivamente sindre questo è lo
spirito no va bene
vi prego datemi una pala che la do
intesa crea chiacchia creato sto gioco
vi prego come battuta t days volo
suicidare credimi a sei già morto ri sui
cittadini come lo chiami un bambino
senza braccia e con una benda
sull'occhio fimi sfortunato nomi
sfortunato che cos'è verde confuso e che
se cade da un albero potrebbe uccidervi
le prime pur table a puntano tavola
biliardo un rinoceronte tavola via
e ho vinto l'oscar per il miglior
premier battute parti spiegatemi il
senso di questo video che vi prego ad
una l'altro in confronto è un manuale di
diritto privato per la serietà cazzo e
dubstep manco skrillex nighter
championship cos'è sta roba da ancora
ancora con le cose della pallina da ping
pong che devo lanciarla al diavolo devo
riuscire a far bere il diavolo va bene
non ci
non è vero ma quanto quanta sfiga possa
avere a veder ci riprovo tech fatto
giusto a brutto stronzo non mi devi fa
bene solo un fantasma io non posso mi
passa tutto attraverso il momento in cui
scopre di avere una vita fantastica è
che quando il diavolo gioca con te a
beer pong ragazze bellissimo a brutto
stronzo come ti permetti
ma come è anche entrata [ __ ] è lui
no certo solo perché il diavolo ma ovvio
raccomandato lo faccio rimbalzare sulla
sua testa ma la sei stronzo proprio a
come non perdo per forza
[Musica]
ho vinto come dressup dai vestiti non ho
capito come dent pooldeck bull dentro il
fantasma e bellissimo feb il software
dolce a ok brendola vi la bistecca la
bistecca malama a carissimo il
cavolfiore identificano ad evocare armi
tutti i denti vai così faqih ecco tutti
i denti cariati bravo zio basta ut des
vado oddio roman race game hanno fatto
un rage dei monkees gioco qua fantastico
se io devo per niente non devo toccare i
bordi che è impossibile
vai vai vai vai veloce veloce veloce la
essere su un provino però io me la devo
tirare continuamente perché quando parlo
santo no cosa come sono molto ma porca
[ __ ] come fatta morire dai cazzo
perché voglio sempre lì da fai mai io no
perché mai mai mai mai mi chiami zona
per riuscirci dio mio sud scegli cosa
scelgo highway to hell stairway to
heaven bellissimo ed ray way mettiamo
questa strada per l'inferno ha dovuto
andarci oddio le paperelle demoniache
quale cosa cazzo vi fumate quando gratis
i videogame benvenuti all'inferno grazie
dio europeo finisce così bellissimo
design mai chiamato in bottiglia da casa
ragazzi ha concluso qui afterlife di
game se qualcuno mi trova il senso mi fa
un piacere quindi ragazzi sparare vino
vi sia piaciuto spero facciano un
qualcosa visto che c'era life game and
after life the game
spero che facciano after afterlife di
game quindi ha quindi ragazzi sparati
nei video vi sia piaciuto concludo vile
episodio cosa il significato argomento
che mi piace anche la pagina di facebook
con un'iscrizione questi scatti ci
vediamo prossimo video e ricordatevi che
c'è sempre un fantasma che riguarda il
culetto potrei essere io ma c'era un
prossimo vi dove l'aria
[Musica]